hola soy Miguel Ortega hitless de la
ciudad de mexico and mexico he stays to
the end old masters of science in
information technology and Carnegie
Mellon and composite of study hola soy
el gordo manana harga Lopez de Lima Peru
hola yo soy ana varela de agua prieta
sonora mexico hola soy adrian espejos
sanchez de bogota colombia y soy C&L
mess ren política pienso ciencia
política public administration en
carnegie mellon campos en australia hola
ya los ninos de san jose costa rica
before I arrived at the Carnegie Mellon
campus in Australia I was posted as the
commercial counselor for the Costa Rican
Embassy in Beijing Costa Rica and China
established the diplomatic relations in
2007 and the president sent the first
diplomatic mission to China which
included me in charge of promoting Costa
Rican trading to China and Chinese
investment intervals to vika both
countries have been negotiating a free
trade agreement and I've been involved
in the process up until last month that
I came here in the summer
I first heard about Carnegie Mellon in
my undergrad because my undergrad school
the attempt have an agreement for
scholarships with Carnegie Mellon in
Pittsburgh mainly and then I decided to
come to the Australia campus because the
program I wanted was here I got a burr
scholarship and I wanted to get to know
this place and all the people around the
main reason I came to this camp wasn't
to take this program is because it is
introduced Ranieri it just makes us
power management and public knowledge
and because value are going to be able
to work in every sector public and
private enterprises and you are going to
learn from many people because they are
from every field of knowledge so it
would be really nice to learn and to
apply oh that
well I was granted a scholarship from
NEC to top it 10 de Fomento cattivo
actually it was one of the main issues
that made me choose well Connie in Milan
it it's it's a very well-known
university in the US however the other
institution I had been at me that is
also a very good very well-known
institution and and they were also
giving me a scholarship but the the
difference that the amount of the
scholarship really was a factor that
that influenced my decision to come here
definitely it gives you a great
advantage especially for us for us latin
american students our so lucky to be
granted as crush it from Coldfoot to do
they were very very helpful the
application was really easy and they can
just help you in all the process and you
should contact the website or people in
Bogota and this will be really nice help
for you I was rental scholarship from
fundación mexicana para la Lucas yo la
tecnología la ciencia hace also called
foo net and the scholarship is helping
me to be here and to continue my studies
also all the process was very simple
they were very friendly and I heard
about it in the Carnegie Mellon website
i'll be graduating this august and
afterwards i hope to go into consulting
I want to do economic development
projects specifically related to Latin
America completion of this program I
expected to return to my country and get
involved in the public policy promotion
in all different sectors private with
corporations public with the government
and definitely with social
entrepreneurship the civil society since
we decree de la Australian three
palabras en trabajo bien duro por Luna
Garcia m nuevos amigos y buenos amigos y
muchas versione al describir la zadeh
our lair Australia yo diría que es una
ciudad y muy a coher hora es una said
limpiar your de nada con mucha
diversidad y la gente que es muy amable
es una cultura muy caliente oh you needa
si tuviera que describir Adelaide
Australian tres palabras Syria
multicultural amigable y